when California law Senator Barbara
Boxer it looked as though the title for
stupidest woman in the US Senate hadn't
lost two but thanks to the election of
Camilla Harris to fill her role
California has retained its title holder
on Friday Harris tweeted judge Gorsuch
has consistently valued narrow legalisms
over real lives I cannot support his
nomination and there was an op-ed to
back to say yep audia contention up in
it Harris argued the gore such a man so
qualified that literally not one
Democrat has to vote against him for his
federal appellate court position was
unqualified to be on the Supreme Court
why because the court quote has the
power to do enormous good and Gorsuch
wouldn't do such good what good would he
/ go as a result of being you know like
a judge according to Harris he would
have voted to strike down laws forcing
teachers to pay union dues because
that's a violation of their First
Amendment rights among other obvious
legal issues but Harris says that
because Gorsuch might take a look at
that stupid old Constitution he cannot
be confirmed she writes as US senators
we have an obligation to also examine
the nominees legal approach and asked
whether he or she considers the impact
of those decisions on our society and
the daily lives of our people hey
wouldn't it be awesome if we had some
sort of like independently elected
branch to make public policy would that
be awesome but according to Harris
judges should fulfill the mandate if
they're a good Marshall who said quote
you you do what you think is right and
let the law catch up which
coincidentally is also something that
every dictator ever has said but never
mind Harris knows what is right for
America judges who openly ignore
legalism in order to apply her standards
of morality I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
venture parish
okay so we are going to get to all of
the hubbub over seven nunez the head of
the house intelligence community and the
supposes scandal surrounding him
visiting the White House we are going to
get to Donald Trump's decision to reach
out to Democrats rather than reaching
out to conservatives we're going to get
some good Trump and some bad trouble the
good Trump bad from today which is
always exciting Plus will deconstruct
the culture but first we should say
thank you to our sponsors over at my
Patriot supply so recently North Korea's
are making a lot of noises about how
they want a new cuts are they actually
going to new cups unlikely but if they
try to then now would be the time to
stock up for your four-week emergency
food supply for just ninety nine dollars
actually got a nice letter from somebody
who is somebody who had gone and got the
the food emergency food supply I
prepared with been calm they said that
there was a floor on their packaging
they immediately sent a note to the
folks over at my patriots apply and they
fix the problem immediately they're
really responsive they're terrific folks
over there prepare with been calm ninety
nine dollars plus free shipping provides
you met four week emergency food supply
which is great because even if you're
not worried about North Korea new king
us you should be worried about a tornado
or an earthquake there's always natural
disasters and it takes a while for the
government to get to people in some of
these cases in some cases the government
just doesn't show up at all and so it's
important that you be able to protect
your family make sure that you have as
much food on hand as you need that's
ninety nine dollars for that four-week
emergency food supply folks in the
office have tried it they say that it
tastes really good prepare with been
calm or 888 803 1413 88 88 0 3 14 13
it's one of those things where you do it
once then you never have to worry about
it again prepare with been calm to get
your four week emergency food supply
which is just something that you should
have on hand regardless of you know
foreign made disasters or natural
disasters you should always be prepared
for an emergency and that's when my
patriots apply it does better than
anybody else okay so the big scandal of
the day is a fake controversy and that
is Devin Nunez he's the head of the
House Intelligence Committee he went
over to the White House apparently and
there he met with some intelligence
official who told him all of the
information that he broke last week now
if your call last week Devin Nunez went
out into the press conference where he
said that Donald Trump's team was
surveilled now you said that they
weren't wiretapped he said that what
happened is that basically the
intelligence officials were wiretapping
all of these all of these diplomats
from foreign countries and those people
had members the trem transition team on
the other line as you imagine they would
and then that information was
disseminated in an irresponsible and or
criminal way so the dissemination of the
information was really the question not
the gathering of the information and
that's an important distinction a lot of
people on Team Trump have been saying
that the intelligence community
illegally gathered information there's
no evidence of that whatsoever do they
illegally disseminate information there
there's actually a fair bit of evidence
that they legally disseminated
information about for example former
national security adviser Mike Flynn but
Democrats in the search for scandal have
been looking somewhere else so what they
say the case that they are making now is
that basically Trump was engaged in some
sort of nefarious activity with Russia
and now they're trying to cover it up so
today the Washington Post says quote the
Trump administration sought to block
former acting Attorney General Sally
Yates from testifying to congress in the
house investigation into links between
russian officials in the Trump campaign
according to a series of letters
reviewed by The Washington Post Yates
was notified earlier this month by the
Justice Department that the
administration considers a great deal of
her possible testimony to be barred from
discussion in a congressional hearing
because the topics are covered by the
presidential communication privilege now
as you recall Barack Obama also asserted
the presidential communication privilege
when he was attempting to defend his
attorney general eric holder from
contempt of congress under republicans
the eight was supposed to testify before
the House Intelligence Committee this
week defying the Trump administration
and then seven nunez mysteriously
canceled the hearing at which she would
testify he now says that she will
testify next week so the media
immediately left to there's some sort of
horrible cover-up in progress and they
said that that cover-up is worse because
last week before Nina's announced all of
this stuff about the intelligence
community disseminating information
wrongly they met Nunez went over to the
White House so what he says he went to
the White House in order to use a secure
computer so that he could look at
intelligence information lachlan marquia
voter the daily beast he says this is
kind of shady the house Intel committee
has his own secure servers there's no
need to use the one at the White House
but what Nunez says is that the
information was not available at
Congress it was only available to the
executive branch that's where the
information was and that his chair of
the House Intel committee he's able to
see such material without reporting it
back to his colleagues he hasn't
revealed what intelligent
vishal actually community and firm it
communicated the information to him and
then he went back to the White House and
told Trump about it now that's the part
that's a little bit Shady the idea that
he went he talked to this intelligence
official and then he didn't tell any of
his committee members and then he wasn't
old Trump well if that were the case
then why didn't the intelligence
official just go tell Trump so people
are latching on to this and they're
saying well this is obviously some sort
of cover-up obviously Nunez was fed
something by the White House and then he
went updated Trump on the feeding and
then he went and out there and parotid
the trump line but there's not a ton of
evidence that that is true there they're
basically two theories about what Nunez
is doing here noon yet hearing number
one is the conspiratorial one that Nunez
knows that there is something nefarious
the trump was doing with Russia and now
he's out there a tempting to misdirect
at the behest of the White House which
is why he visited the White House both
before and after he went out and
announced all of this stuff and and this
has led to a tremendous breakdown in the
House Intelligence Committee and they've
canceled all their hearings for this
week because people can't get along but
here's the counterfactual here's another
possibility let's imagine for a second
that Obama intelligence community
members are widely dispersing
information illegally which is probably
true and let's assume that Nunez found
out about this from some sort of
intelligence community whistleblower who
didn't want to go directly to trump
because he doesn't trust Trump also very
plausible because Trump has a big mouth
Trump says whatever comes to his mind
and he wouldn't want Trump to get him in
trouble so instead he uses Nunez's
discovery calls of nuñez he says listen
it's your job to figure out how to
disseminate this information but I
thought you ought to know you're the one
on the Oversight Committee so you come
and you see me right now Nunez goes to
the White House to speak to that person
because it's an executive branch agency
and then he doesn't allow the eight
testimony or at least the White House
fights the H testimony not because they
think that Yates has something that they
need to keep hidden but because eh is
just going to go out there and be a
political hack which again is not
implausible because after all yay is a
political hack she was fired if you
recall by the Trump administration for
refusing to defend problems travel ban
in court when she was acting Attorney
General both of those theories are
plausible but the media is only covering
one of those theories and the Democrats
are only pushing one of those theories
and that is the nunez Trump cover-up
theory and again the big question and
all of that is where's the scandal if
there's going to be a cover-up you
assume something had to be done that was
wrong so far the only thing I know that
was done that was wrong
any of this is that there were
intelligence officials who worked for
Obama who are leaking a bunch of
information to the press and leaking a
bunch of information to the rest of the
intelligence community and unmasking
people that's the only thing I know was
done wrong here I don't know anything
was done wrong between the Trump team
and Russia you know you can suspect
whatever you want there's no evidence
yeah I don't know that anything was done
in terms of coordination with WikiLeaks
I don't know that neither do you neither
does anybody else again what's funny
about this is that among all the leaks
that have happened from the intelligence
community to the press the one thing
that hasn't been leaked to the actual
definitive information that says that
Trump was connected to Russia still none
of that there's all the smoke but
there's no fire and so it's just as
plausible as the cover-up theory that
basically this is an incompetently
handled just normal order of business
routine from Devin Nunez and president
Trump so here is nuñez explaining why he
went to the White House grounds in the
first place the Congress has not been
given this information these documents
and that's the problem so so because the
because this is executive branch it was
distributed widely through the executive
branch this was from november december
in january and these were reports this
let me reiterate this had nothing to do
with Russia nothing do the Russia
investigation there is no way for the
folks that I had been working with to
actually to bring this forward to light
there was no way I could view that
because they couldn't get it to the
House Intelligence Committee ok so he
sort of says that I'm not going to be
able to transmit that to the House
Intelligence Committee the House Intel
Democrats are saying what the hell why
are you get to see and I don't get to
see it Chuck Schumer the the Senate
Minority Leader he says that the public
should immediately fire Nunez basically
mr. president if speaker Ryan wants the
house to have a credible investigation
he needs to replace chairman Nunez and
then that is followed up on immediately
by Mark Warner who's senator from from
Virginia and he says that basically
nuñez has to go I am totally mystified
by what mr. noon is have said
and I've talked to my chairman richard
burr he doesn't know I talk to Democrats
Republicans on the committee I think
it's fairly mystifying if not outrageous
that he make these claims then this goes
down and breach the White House okay and
finally you have nuñez responding i
guess i'm being told that it's not
pronounced Nunez even though everybody
pronounce it that way it's actually
pronounced Newton's I have no idea
whether that's true in any case Devon
Newtons he says that Democrats actually
just want him out because he's effective
effective at what nobody really
understands yeah well I'm sure that the
Democrats do want me to quit because
they know that I'm a quite effective at
getting to the bottom all right well
it's hello congressman okay so he says
that he's effective at getting to the
bottom of things I doubt that's why
Democrats want him to quit I think the
Democrats want him to quit because one
it would look like he's guilty and two
because he will act as a shield for
Trump in this I mean just to be
perfectly honest with you whenever you
have a member of the party of the
president who's investigating the
President himself it is very rare that
you get an honest incredible
investigation very difficult to get an
honest credible investigation of the
president when the person who's leading
the investigation was on the Trump
transition team which Devin Nunes or
Nunez was so I think that it is
perfectly fair to say the media is over
blowing this case and this is a fake
scandal and that we don't even know
what's going on yet and it is also
perfectly fair to say that if you
actually want a credible investigation
that is going to be listened to by the
vast majority of Americans you can't
have somebody who's on drums transition
team leading the investigation into
Trump it's just not going to work that
way but all this is leading the left to
lose their minds and they're absolutely
going crazy so senator chris coons of
connecticut he says that the GOP for
example on judge Gorsuch they should
never ever ever use the what they call
the nuclear option they should let the
filibuster stand like course which go
down to the few minutes just insane it's
insane all right well so then the
Republicans are going to pass it using
the so-called nuclear almost certainly
and I think this is tragic and in
talking to friends on both sides they
all we've got a lot of senators
concerned about where we're headed okay
again the only reason they're talking
about using the nuclear option is
because they are talking about
filibustering a Supreme Court nominee
which has never been done before as far
as I'm aware so and again this is
democrats losing their minds because
they don't know what to do with with
gore
they don't know what to do with Trump
they're very frustrated I understand
some of the frustration but some of that
is just endemic and not being in the
party in power Bernie Sanders is back
and he says that he hopes that the GOP
does not change the rules when it comes
to approving Supreme Court nominees what
concerns me is that right now we have a
rule that says appropriately I think
that for a Supreme Court justice a life
time term one of the most important
positions in the United States
government that it should require 60
votes because that would make it
bipartisan and I think that that's not
what the Constitution says it doesn't
say that require 60 votes it says that
it requires 51 votes it's the Democrats
are insisting on 60 votes and of course
the Democrats nukes the filibuster along
with Harry Reid long ago so the idea
that it's no longer on the table that
you can't do that that's just absolute
nonsense how crazy are the Democrats
going at this point there's now a report
that's out the Chuck Schumer actually
started ranting at somebody who voted
for Donald Trump at a restaurant in New
York last night according to multiple
witnesses is over a daily wire as well
as the victim of the ugly episode the
leading Democrat in the Senate New
York's own Chuck Schumer lost it at a
swanky Manhattan restaurant on Sunday
after he learned that a well-connected
woman had voted for Trump after making a
scene inside by declaring she voted for
Trump Schumer allegedly followed the
woman and her well-known Democrat
husband outside repeatedly screaming
he's a liar apparently this happened in
Upper West Side restaurants and
apparently it was the Democrat Joseph
Califano jr. remember the board of
directors at CBS who served as the
Secretary of Health Education and
Welfare for under under Jimmy Carter so
he was very upset that California's wife
had voted for Trump and say actually
start berating her in front of the crowd
that's how crazy Democrats are going
just to prove how nuts they are chris
matthews we have a state that comes out
i show he comes on the air he says yeah
vodka Trump Jared people it's like it's
about me saying kids ah you know we
can't I kid about everything but you
know uday and qusay working for Saddam
Hussein you couldn't go to a restaurant
and have eye contact one of those guys
not getting killed like these people are
really powerful imagine getting to a
fight in the office with Jared or Ivanka
that they have
enormous power and they're always going
to be there this is what I worry about
for other people in the White House is
Olga Trampas vision described as her
father's eyes and ears on the ground
that's a little scary if you're just a
regular White House staffer who maybe
wants to offer advice that criticizes
the president this is a person who t is
the number one trait that is that Trump
carries with that you remember people in
the chris matthews over nemesis you
remember when Chris Matthews I other
state Murray said Jesse Clinton and she
was Hillary Clinton you just know you
know that if you look at Hilary Clinton
cross-eyed you'll get Chelsea cross-eyed
Hillary will jump on you and Carrie
throat out like a dog radially jugular
because just like Saddam Hussein it's
just like like yah note Mussolini ah
he's going to shoot his own son-in-law
but o me later until then he's a lie I
mean like how much are they losing their
minds when he's comparing Ivanka Trump
who is by the way Jewish comparing her
to a and kousei who say who are
literally mass murderers who had rape
this is how insane the left is gone
they've lost all connection with reality
so whatever problems we have here over
on the right the left is certainly not
taking advantage of them because they
are just awful they don't even know how
to handle any of this well we're going
to talk some good Trump bad Trump after
this Plus what's happening in the wake
of Trump care going down but first I
want to say thank you to our newest
sponsors over at MV mts this is movement
movement watches so this watch that I
have right here at this very cool
looking watch this i got from mvmt it
was founded on the belief that style
shouldn't cost a ton of money it was
started by these two guys who basically
wanted to undercut the pricing on
watches because watches can be really
expensive I love watches I own like
three or four of them this is it this is
the nicest watch that I own I wear this
one every day actually I had a watch
from another brand and after I got my
movement watch my mvmt watch and you can
get your watch at mvmt watches calm when
you when i got this watch actually put
the others in the drive been wearing
this one every day since I think it's
really cool looking I know that that
Clavin has 12 really nice-looking
watches they're very stylish they fit
really well
and it's you know it's a terrific
company okay they started 95 bucks at a
department store this would be like a
four or five hundred dollar watch so
really really nice watch and they
figured out that if they sold on the
line and they'd be able to you know do
the branded thing for a lot less money
right now if you go to mvmt watches calm
/ Shapiro fifteen percent off with free
shipping and free returns fifteen
percent off free shipping and free
returns when you use mvmt watches calm /
Shapiro make sure you add the / appear
so they know that we say again their
watches are just top-notch it's clean
designed everything looks very sleek and
it's exactly kind of watch the that I
like and that they don't all have to
look you know sort of more dark and
athletic like that they have
classic-looking watches as well they've
women's watches that are really nice i'm
gonna get one for my wife really
top-notch material at a competitive
prices mvmt watches calm / Shapiro I
love the watch i can't speak more highly
than that of the product okay so i think
we're going to do a little too good
Trump bad Trump but first you're going
to have to go over to daily wire calm
and you come become a subscriber if you
want to watch it live plus we're going
deconstruct some cultures how Beauty and
the Beast actually so you're going to
want to go over to daily wire calm right
now eight dollars a month will buy you a
subscription to daily wired com plus if
you get an annual subscription they get
a free signed copy of Michael J Knowles
PhD his his best-selling book reasons to
vote Democrat a comprehensive guide as I
say incredibly thorough sure the book is
blank but still it's a great book and
it's worth having in your library more
importantly it's worth getting a free
signed copy and sending it to all of
your annoying Democrat family members
because it's hilarious daily wire calm
eight dollars a month get to a
subscription annual subscription you get
Knowles's book plus I keep saying there
will be a Shapiro store there will be a
Shapiro store there's plenty of gear and
we are getting it ready right now as we
speak in the back room I have a bunch of
illegal immigrants working on it and
until they're deported then they will be
working on all the Shapiro gear in the
back at that point o switch to American
made product as though our running for
president is almost in any case then go
over to daily wire calm and check it out
or listen later in itunes and soundcloud
we are the largest conservative podcast
in the nation
[Music]
you